[Music]
hi I'm Garrett Riesman
former NASA astronaut and today we're
going to look at some popular movie
clips and I'll try to use my experience
as a former director of space operations
at SpaceX and current professor at
universities in California USC and give
you a rating on how realistic it is you
have to let me go or we both die
D'Argo's oh yeah that was bogus
I really like this movie despite the
fact that the science totally wrong this
movie takes great liberties and
completely blows off the basic laws of
physics the movie deals with space
debris and that's what causes the
calamity that they then have to fight
the rest of the movie this is a real
problem and it's getting worse so some
of the stuff is natural but the vast
bulk of the flux the density of the
stuff whizzing around the earth is
created by humans it's stuff that we've
shot up into space and we didn't clean
up our own mess when I was up there
several times I heard debris hit the
space station there's certain things in
the movie about how they showed the
debris that's not accurate you can see
it coming in the movie you see this like
cloud of debris coming from thousands of
kilometers away that's that's bogus okay
this stuff is traveling an order of
magnitude like ten times faster than a
rifle bullet you can't look at it at a
shooting range and see a rifle bullet
flying around from thousands of
kilometers away you're not gonna see
this stuff coming and the other thing
about this that's completely unrealistic
George Clooney is flying on by and
Sandra Bullock reaches and grabs his
tether and grabs onto him that would be
hard as he's flying on by he would with
his momentum try to carry her away and
pull her away from the space station and
she would have to resist that and stop
him which she does yay
Sandra Bullock you have saved the day
well done and a story it should end
right there there's no gravity right
that that's pulling away it's not it's
not like she's holding him like over a
cliff or something he is not pulling her
off the space station anymore the work
is done and once she has stopped his
motion and he's just sitting there and
she's holding onto the other end of the
tether all she has to do is go like this
with a little this pinky and and pull
him and he would be going right back to
the space station and he'd be having a
nice lunch together he says you have to
let me go why why does she have to let
him go and you've got a firm grip on
George Clooney you do not let go okay no
matter what the laws of is
say you hold on this whole idea about
puncturing your glove to fly like Iron
Man be rescued by your spaceship yeah
not so much we have a jetpack that we
wear when we do spacewalks on the space
station we needed to have something to
do if you became untethered and started
floating off and you're going to become
lost in space during a spacewalk that's
what we added these jetpacks
it's just nitrogen and it's just little
puffs of nitrogen that come out of those
little Jets is enough to let you fly
back to the space station and stop you
from being lost in space now first of
all you would need a spacesuit
pressurized really really high to get
enough pressure to actually get the kind
of thrust that he gets in reality just
be a little it's gonna be a tiny little
gentle push it's not gonna be a it's
gonna be a you know come on
so that's the first thing is wrong but
if you do have this big rocket engine
coming out of your hand
and you're trying to control yourself
now you've got to put that thrust
through your center of gravity so you
got to hold it very very precisely and
any kind of motion away from from the
proper direction there's gonna cause you
start tumbling out of control you can be
like like if you take a balloon and blow
it up and then just release it and it
goes a little over the place no way
you're gonna be like flying back where
you want to go so bogus
big-time bogus on that the rest of movie
was up like a nine the rest of movie is
really really good
[Music]
the scene in Star Wars where Luke
Skywalker who uses the force and
destroys the Death Star by attacking its
one hidden weakness so a couple things
pop out right away one is you know
what's with the orange ski goggles on
Luke in the middle of black space I mean
really you need that and then finally
like Han Solo's wearing this earpiece
though that microphone thing it looks
like he's a telemarketer it looks like
you should sell you some insurance or
something but the big thing is they blow
up the Death Star right which is awesome
and it goes now that wouldn't happen I
mean you're not gonna hear anything
because sound needs a medium to
propagate through so right now you're
hearing me talk because as vibrations go
on in my throat and air goes through
that and air molecules vibrate they
vibrate other air molecules and because
we have air in this room it reaches the
microphone and causes vibrations on the
microphone and then you hear that if
there's no air here but other than that
you wouldn't be able to hear me the
thing is that if you're watching a movie
and you see a big explosion and it's
silent it doesn't feel right to the
audience so I understand why movie
editors and special effects guys put the
sound in but it's bogus you can't see
explosions and there can be fire even in
the vacuum of space you actually need
three things you need spark you need
fuel and then you need oxygen for it to
cool off then you will see flame you
will see fire even in the vacuum of
space you won't hear anything but you'll
see it so that is plausible
that behind a hay guy he looks just like
me huh so I say obviously the casting
people know what they're doing
did you get it yet tars that's why I'm
here
I'm gonna find a way to tell me how Wow
so that was pretty trippy huh if I
remember it from the movie he's inside a
black hole at this point where the
forces of gravity are so strong that not
even light can escape but recently we
got our first picture of a black hole
really what's around the black hole
because once light goes into the event
horizon the circle around the black hole
nothing comes out and inside the black
all nobody knows what happens inside
there nothing ever comes back if a
person went inside a black hole what
would it really be like who knows but
you do see the light bending in there
and it is true that light will Bend but
when it's exposed to very strong
gravitational fields a lot of the stuff
that they did in this movie they tried
to be as realistic as possible but I do
have a problem with there's this
bookshelf tesseract thing so some
advanced civilization created this
tesseract where you go into this thing
and it's like line wood books on the
shelf and by pulling the books off the
shelf you could see into other
dimensions and you could communicate to
people in those other dimensions in a
very very roundabout incredibly
complicated way if you are a super
advanced alien intelligence that can
build a bookshelf tesseract thing to go
across dimensions why can't you put in a
phone or at least put in like a
whiteboard right with a dry erase marker
that you could just spelled it like hey
stay away from the black hole you know
whatever and send the message that way
why do you have to get so complicated
but other than that they got a lot of
stuff right especially about the
relativistic effects in the movie
this is one of my all-time favorite
space films and what's really amazing
about it is how realistic it is
considering they filmed all of this
before Apollo 11 before we landed men on
the moon and the science in the movie
holds up tremendously well there the one
thing that's missing there and then the
opening scene there is the atmosphere
you just see the blue earth and then
suddenly the black space in reality when
you look at the Earth from space there's
a bin blue line that separates the
sunlit earth from the blackness of space
so you might be asking yourself why is
the Space Station spinning and why is it
constructed as a big wheel what you're
doing is you're creating inertial forces
that simulate gravity and have the same
effect because the absence of gravity
causes some problems to the human body
it causes for example some bone loss now
you're up in space and you're floating
around like a fish and the bones are
like it I guess I don't need to make any
more bone your muscles in especially in
your legs start to atrophy because
you're not using your legs anymore
you're not walking so all kinds of like
funky and not-so-good things happen to
your body in space so we fight it we
fight it hard and mostly by working out
and we get we have to do it about two
hours a day every day but hey what if we
can create artificial gravity then we
wouldn't have to do any of this and we
wouldn't have any of these problems
that's the idea behind the spinning
spaceship and the best way I can explain
that is in his old amusement park rides
over like a big washing machine you get
in and it starts spinning and it throws
you up against the wall and then the
floor drops out and you don't fall
because you're being pushed back against
the wall by a pseudo force we call
centrifugal force that's what's
happening here in the space station by
spinning like that you could create
centrifugal force that acts and feels
like artificial gravity if you're
creating artificial gravity with a small
radius like those rides an amusement
park that make you go against the wall
you can handle that spinning for a
couple of minutes you don't wanna be
spending months in there right you need
to avoid having the radius too small
that you get what's called Coriolis
effects then make sure you kind of dizzy
you don't want that you also need to be
spinning fast enough so if you walk the
opposite direction you don't start
floating so you have to have a rim speed
that's typical about six meters per
second which is bigger than your average
person walks so a lot of times in the
movies
either it's not long enough or it's
spinning too slow for it to really do
its job
there's 2001 get it right yes it does if
you look at that thing and you time the
rate of the rotation and you try to
estimate how big it is the radius is
about 150 meters and it's spinning at
about 1 and 1/2 R p.m. that's enough to
get you of almost half a G so almost
half the gravity that you feel on earth
which is probably good enough so that's
not bad if those numbers are accurate
which it kind of made it up so you know
but I think it's real close
you look any movie with the talking
raccoon is okay in my book
boy okay first of all it's great that
he's got this mask on so he can breathe
in space but what about the rest of his
body the rest of your body is gonna be
in really really bad shape the fluids
inside your tissues is gonna vaporize
and so basically your blood is gonna
boil all the water and your tissue is
gonna turn into gas he takes off his
helmet and to try to save his friend
there somehow holds his breath now it's
true that you can survive for very brief
periods of time while exposed to a
vacuum it has been done there's been
accidents on earth in vacuum chambers
and and if you get quickly back down to
regular pressure you're gonna be okay
but there's a couple things you worry
about the first thing you have to worry
about Barrow traumas what that means is
that there's gas inside your body in
your lungs in your sinuses and that's
going to start expanding once you get
exposed to vacuum because now instead of
having the outside air pressure to work
against now there's nothing out here
it's gonna want to blow up like a
balloon then you worry about
decompression sickness where all the
nitrogen comes out of the solution in
your blood
the scuba divers can get when they spend
too much time at depth and come up too
quickly they called the bends cuz you
bend over and pain at all your joints
where the bubbles build up so all that
would happen to star-lord even before he
takes off his mask
having said that did I mention that this
movie has a talking raccoon you're
worried about the helmet I mean it's
kind of talking raccoon
[Music]
[Music]
true story I used this clip in my class
here at USC when I was teaching this
subject about what happens if you do get
exposed to vacuum and I tell people we
actually have a test subject that
volunteered in NASA we did an experiment
and we have video of that experiment
here it is and I show that clip and they
get a good laugh out of it because no
that's not really terribly accurate what
would happen if you were exposed to
space and we're not adequately protected
and that is when parts of your body
parts of your tissues the liquid
vaporizes turns into a gas and you puff
up like a balloon presumably that would
happen around your face as well but it
wouldn't look exactly like that that's a
little Hollywood magic right there
another thing about this clip is that he
hits a rock and the visor shatters and
he heard shatter like it's glass most
face student helmets are made out of
polycarbonate which is much tougher when
it's shatter quite like that you can
break your space helmet and so tumbling
down surface on Mars and whacking your
head into a rock is not recommended
we're losing power why cuz we're gonna
guess okay we'll have to set her down
prepare for emergency landing
[Music]
I can't believe you actually want me to
comment I'm the scientific realism of
space balls there flying around space in
a Winnebago with a dog man as your
second-in-command and really you want me
to talk about whether or not it violates
the laws of physics what do I start
first issue is if you're traveling in
between planets even between solar
systems in the future once you're on
your trajectory you're not burning your
engines anymore for example when we went
to the moon we got into Earth orbit we
lit the engines up to get enough
velocity to escape Earth orbit and get
on a trajectory going towards the moon
but that only lasted minutes and then
once we had that velocity and we're
heading in the right direction at the
right speed we shut the engines down and
you coast so if you run out of gas you
don't fall out of the sky you're going
to continue coasting in the same
direction and the same trajectory you
had before but again you know it's a
Winnebago what do you want me to tell
you anyway if you can accept all that
and you're run out of fuel now you fall
which is wrong but now you had to
crash-land on this planet and it's a
desert that can happen you know Earth
has got deserts obviously earth isn't
planet Mars and the moon both have a lot
of sand like soil we call regolith so
it's not unrealistic that if you came
down on the planet that there would be a
desert with lots of sand hold on
when you're way out in the future and
you're like Star Trek time super
advanced with photon torpedoes and
phasers and stuff and green women you
can just speculate that you got some
advanced technology so in the Star Trek
world we just have gravity plates that
is degrading according to Spock in this
clip and you can just wave your hands
and do that the thing about that is let
me tell you a story I was up on the
space station and when you're up on the
space station they ask you would you
like to talk to anybody like any
celebrities or interesting people and
they do that as kind of a morale boost
so I said yeah I would like to talk to
Ron Moore and David Icke they are the
people that created Battlestar Galactica
we had this video teleconference and I
said to them you know you did the same
thing you'd come up with this artificial
gravity on Galactica everybody's just
walking around like they're on earth but
you're out in the middle of space
where's the gravity coming from why do
you have to do that like why would you
take away like one of the coolest things
about being up here the ability to fly
and Ron Morris said to me said Garrett
you have any idea how expensive those
special effects are and all those stunts
so I get why especially if you're doing
something like bow start Galactica or
Star Trek that you'd want to just say oh
artificial gravity so I'm not going to
knock Star Trek down deadly co2 gas is
literally poisoning
okay we have a an unusual procedure for
you here
once you rip the cover off the flight
plan which pleasure - lithium hydroxide
canisters Houston filters in place so
yes that really happened they had a big
challenge because they had to find some
way of scrubbing out the carbon dioxide
inside the command module of Apollo 13
without having it powered up so humans
make carbon dioxide we consume oxygen we
breathe out carbon dioxide and if that
gets too high bad things happen you get
headaches and eventually you can even
die if the carbon dioxide levels get too
high for now on earth we have a
wonderful thing it's called plants that
do this for us and during Apollo 13 or
in any spacecraft you have to somehow
accomplish it without having plants and
so we use a chemical called lithium
hydroxide it absorbs the co2 but you use
it up but like on the Space Shuttle we
had to change out the canisters of Lyall
lithium hydroxide every so often so they
couldn't use the equipment inside the
command module that normally takes all
the carbon dioxide that we spew out and
scrubs that out of the air explosion
oxygen tanks are gone
to find some way to do it in using the
lunar lander which wasn't intended to be
used for that period of time for three
people had to use some of the canisters
from the command module the thing was
the command module and the lunar module
were made by two different companies
because there are two different
companies they actually made them two
different shapes so one was round and
one was square well they came up with a
pretty good plan which is that they made
an adapter by using the cardboard or the
cover of the flight plan some duct tape
and some hose and they found a way to
make an adapter to use this square
around Holden it's really the workaround
that they came up with and it worked and
so what you seen that movie is a hundred
percent real they even used actual
dialogues you know NASA recorded all the
transmissions to and from the spaceship
and on the intercom and so they had
transcripts of what actually happened
during the real Apollo 13 and we've got
a problem here this is Houston say again
please houston we have a problem Apollo
13 is the gold standard they got it
right more than probably any other movie
ever made about space this movie is this
closest thing to being a documentary
without actually taking cameras up and
filming it in space that you in space no
one can hear you scream would you test
that for me right now could you scream
for us yeah sure Steven I'd be happy to
it's true it's true no one can hear you
scream
[Applause]